[Music]
hey what's up this is john with the dr
john deloney show
on today's show a conservative and a
liberal
fall in love now what and a sister
is caught between her sister and her
sister's boyfriend
and mom and dad and nobody approves of
anybody
and we're talking about setting
boundaries with a son who just got out
of rehab
how do we love and support and hold him
accountable
stay tuned hey what is up
i'm john and this is the dr john deloney
show
we're talking about your life your
relationships your relational iq your
mental health
that idiot annoying neighbor
that drives you crazy borrows your crap
and doesn't return it we're talking
about everything everything
and listen if you if you even
walk by a television you see that the
world's
literally burning down around us here's
the deal it's not
it's not smoke cells right fire sells
actually i i did hear that there's
places in the country that are actually
on fire right now so those places are
burning down
but most of the things are not it just
feels like it is
and i want to hear from you i want to
hear what you think is on fire what's
hurting in your heart what's hurting in
your home
and i want to help everybody make the
next right decision
make the next good decision to think
through what's going on in their heart
and minds so give me a call
1-844-693-3291 that is
1-844-693-3291
this is a caller-driven show it's about
you
it's for you and it's by you
real calls real conversations with
real people with real pain and so the
show is for you
again that's 1-844-693-3291
or you can email me at ask john
ramseysolutions.com
and you can leave your your name your
number
tell me what's going on and we will
reach out and get in touch with you and
see if we can connect
to have you on the show so i'm excited
we got a whole slate of calls today
let's go straight to the phones let's go
to lynn
in topeka kansas lynn good morning how
in the world are you
hi dr melanie i'm good thank you so much
for calling
oh you're welcome um i wanted to get
your insight
on how i can set up my relationship for
success
when we have conflicting opinions um
i'm in a dating relationship of about
seven months and it's getting serious
um but we disagree on almost all
political
and even almost coveted like issues
so what is you said you said that
awesome so it's getting serious
and we disagree on everything so when
you say we
when you say seriously what is that on
our face you oh so you agree on
faith yeah and what faith is that
okay you're both christian so you love
christians so if i
so serious means um you've gone from
holding hands
like this to now you're lacing fingers
is that where we're at now
like it's it's crossing over right ah
okay
five he's 45. oh okay um
i think we're just in a place in life
where we know what we want now and
okay so this is just first first
if y'all got married would this be first
marriages for both of you
it would okay all right so you're
getting serious you know what you
both want you think he's pretty good
looking
he thinks you're hot stuff enough to
keep around for seven months right
um you both are christians so you have
the religious thing down
you just disagree on everything else
and covet um what is walk me through
what that is like
well you know it comes up in ways you
don't think but like even we
disagree on immigration and i made a
friend who
is undocumented and i was unsure about
how to tell him about that because
i know he doesn't see that the same way
i do or
guns he owns a gun i wouldn't want a gun
in my house
we need to compromise on that somehow
on covid we both don't want to go to
church but he doesn't want to for his
own
convenience of not wearing a mask
whereas i want to protect my family and
it's just we see things differently so
you're experiencing something that
hundreds of millions of people across
the world
are experiencing which is the pressure
of covid
is helping squish out disagreements and
um helping really magnify
cracks in relationships right so when
you've when you've seen some of these
things
pop out um things like immigration guns
um i'm just gonna i'm gonna guess here
you got immigration and guns
and masks so i'm gonna assume that um
climate change is the thing uh lgbt
rights is a thing
um whatever who we're voting for are all
those things too
like it's all this big a pile of
shenanigans okay so
um what do you want to do do you want to
marry this guy or no i i want to work it
out yeah
i want to i want to be able to
respect him but i feel like sometimes i
just need him
to make decisions i can understand
with facts we agree on but sometimes we
don't even agree on the facts
you know and that makes it harder for me
to respect
his opinion hmm okay
so when you let me so let me let me
put this out there and then we can kind
of walk through a little bit so there's
this idea of values versus beliefs
and i had this epiphany a few weeks ago
and it's really kind of warmed its way
through my head down into my heart and
here's the idea
values are these unflinchable things
right and values are
i treat people with dignity and respect
i don't
steal i love everybody
and i take those three things and then i
have these different beliefs
which means that may inform how i
see immigration right um here's an
easier one
and i i work here with dave ramsey and
here's an example of something that
happens to us in real time on the dave
ramsey show
dave and i share values that we both
love people right deeply
and we both share um this idea that we
want
people to be treated with dignity and
then some and we both want to respect
people and we want to help people those
are values we share
and then somebody calls and they say hey
i just took out a giant loan
of a bajillion dollars for a
depreciating car
um and uh my husband's mad
and so dave may feel like the best way
to help them is to get loud
and to do a classic dave ramsey rant and
be like what are you doing and
my default setting my my way of thinking
i'm going to help them my belief
is i'm going to get quiet and be like
hey look dude what are you doing
right we have the same values with
different beliefs
and what you and your husband are you oh
i screwed that one up you and your
um hot stuff seven month fiance uh
fiance dating relationship whatever you
want to call them
you have to decide are your values the
same and is that okay with different
beliefs so here's the deal i've been
with the same woman for 20 something
years
dating and married we've got very
different beliefs on
some core issues but we share similar
values
my concern with what you have presented
so far is you
have stated i don't know if i respect
him which tells me there's a
value issue and it sounds conversely he
doesn't
listen to me because he gets hot-headed
and he gets all up in his feelings
and doesn't look at data doesn't look at
facts gets fired up
and i don't feel respected so am i on to
something there
you know i would say it's probably like
an 80
20 you know like eight percent of the
time he listens
and it's really good i really it's
really good sometimes he just brings
you know his his feelings um
and that kind of ends the conversation
because you can't argue with someone's
feelings there
you have to respect those feelings and
so that's how you feel you know that's
i understand that and i accept that and
um
so the big question is do you a accept
that and b
will you accept that 10 years from now
or 20 years from now yeah
or to distill it down into a very
visceral real moment
you have a good friend who's a good
human being
he's got a great soul and they're
undocumented
and that person comes to you and says
hey listen i just got evicted from my
apartment i need a place to stay
and your christian faith says come to my
house
i've got a bed for you and you're
married to a christian guy who says my
christian
faith says i will not have someone who
is violating the laws of the land or
whatever his rationale for it is
and they're not welcome in my house
that's the conversation you need to have
that's good because you're gonna have to
you are making these things about ideas
and again values are very tangible
beliefs come and go
i've been an educator for my whole
professional life
i hope over time my beliefs evolve and
change that's why i read
books that's why i've got friends listen
lin i've got friends who make bernie
sanders look a little bit right a center
they are so far over the left i mean
it's it's comical
and i've got friends on the right that
even trump would be like
whoa guys let's rein it in right so i
surround myself with people who see the
world differently than me
one because i just love folks but two
i'm always looking for ways i can shape
and mold and move my beliefs around
and so that's why i read books that's
why i
i don't consume a ton of media but
that's the goal right
and if you have somebody whose values
are
here's the ever ending truth there is a
period at the end of all of life
sentences
and i don't have any interest in
changing my beliefs that's something
you're going to have to manage and child
and challenge yourself with and deal
with
but i'll tell you this this won't go
away
this will just manifest itself in each
one of you
taking a dive being silent being quiet
or this is going to be an extraordinary
opportunity for you
and this guy who you've been with for
seven months and you think i'm kind of
leaning
heavier and heavier into this one being
our forever relationship
this could be a remarkable moment for
you to sit down
and go through what are our values
how do i talk to you when you have state
of feeling
i feel that climate change isn't real
and you say yeah but the data says this
how do you want me to respond to you a
handsome handsome man of mine
and let him talk to you because it may
be a moment of vulnerability
his feelings may be a moment of him
saying i don't know what i believe i
don't want that to be true so i'm just
going to feel angry about it
i'm just going to feel frustrated about
it or how do you
lean in when you say i just feel like
this person needs to come over to our
house
and he says yeah but the facts are it's
against the law
how do you want him to respond to your
feelings right
this could be a great moment for clarity
for
for really digging into who you are as a
couple
and i want to leave this one this one
little
nugget um there are
some there is some data some
neurosciences suggest that how we feel
about
topics and people and circumstances
influences how we feel facts i mean i'm
sorry how we hear
facts how we hear data and what's
fascinating about this and frustrating
and kind of frightening is
um if you are super conservative
let's say you are super conservative and
you hear
data here is one plus one equals
two on a more liberal cause
it can actually reinforce your
conservative values and you flip the
whole thing over right
if you are uber left wing you are so far
left you're almost making a complete
loop around
and somebody says hey here's just some
facts about how economics works
here's some facts about we need to pay
our bills and not have debt
it can actually reinforce that so this
whole idea that feelings don't matter
only the facts that's not actually a
fact
the fact is is that your feelings
influences how you hear facts
and facts influence your feelings it's
reciprocal they work together
and so as a in a relationship in a
community in a country
the starting point is not i've got more
feelings and i'm angry or
i've got more facts and i'm right it's
really sitting down and saying
i feel vulnerable i feel out of control
here's the way i'm feeling this here's
how i'm seeing this what are you seeing
and then someone can say i'm looking at
the same data and i'm seeing it this way
i have these feelings and i'm feeling
this way and if we can start there
you can slowly start to come together on
okay what are our shared
values our beliefs are going to move and
mold and shift and go with the wind
what are our core values
and from there if you share values
there's very little that you can't do as
a couple there just isn't there's just
very little you can't overcome as a
community
very little you can't overcome as a
country um
but if you don't share values if you
don't share this idea that anybody and
i'm using your
your thought going back to lynn here
you're a situation
if a core value is anybody's welcome in
my home
and one of your husband's core values is
there are only certain people
welcome in my home not your husband your
boyfriend that's going to be a value
issue that's going to be
very very difficult to get over in a
long-term relationship so
i recommend go out to lunch go out to
breakfast sit down and talk about values
sit down and talk about how you're
vulnerable with one another sit down and
talk about your
how do you want each other to process
feelings
and then see if he's the guy for you see
if he's the guy for you if you choose
that he is if you decide that he is or
if you decide he's not call me back lynn
now i'm all invested in this deal um
i've got a picture of what he looks like
in my head and i would love to see that
wedding photo someday
if you choose to pull the trigger on it
so um thank you so much for the call
let's go out to leah in tallahassee
florida
leah how in the world are you i
am good dr d thanks for being on the
team this year we have all
needed it thank you so much i'm grateful
for you so how can i help
well my sister is dating someone who
my parents and i see as not being
equally yoked
um regarding some of their values
actually
and i'm just having some trouble being
caught in the middle of it
so explain to me what caught in the
middle looks like
uh both parties calling and complaining
about
each other um and
i agree with where my parents are at
and i don't necessarily agree with where
my sister is coming from so i'm just
having some difficulties
um with loving them both
and not being caught in the middle not
being that person that they are calling
and complaining to
um yeah
so this is a
classic classic relational triangulation
is what they call it in nerd school
and you have become the point of tension
release for your parents
leaning against your sister and vice
versa and so
the first and most important thing is to
honor everybody is to get
out of your triangle triangulated
position
back out okay um if you
allow yourself to be triangulated by
your parents and your sister
then what's to happen is you're going to
end up
burning the whole system to the ground
or you're going to be the flash point by
which they burn the whole system to the
ground
so the best way to step out of this is
this number one tell your parents hey
listen i love my sister i've heard you
guys
i don't want you all to talk bad about
my sister anymore and i know
that's a challenging hard conversation
how old are you by the way
i am 32. yeah there you go so you're an
adult you're a grown woman
um this is a grown-up conversation
that just says hey mom hey dad i can't
do it anymore
um she's my sister she's making
decisions that i don't totally agree
with
um but i can't keep going back and forth
between you two and then you sit down
with your sister and have that hard
conversation which is hey listen
i can't have you talking bad about mom
and dad anymore like you're making your
decisions you're a
grown-up i'm assuming she's a grown-up
too is that right
yes okay um and then you lay
your thoughts and opinions down for what
they are and then you love and support
your sister
i guess you can walk away and abandon
your sister whatever the the um decision
she's making what are they by the way
what are these
decisions she's making they're they're
unequally yoked
i don't really like him what does
unequally yoked mean
well they he's not a christian
and she says that she's very strong in
her beliefs and her values
but it just seems that it's actually a
lot like a
call before mine and i just see
this being a struggle for them in their
marriage especially if they bring
kids into the picture if they're not on
the same page with
religion and politics and all of the
above
and it's it's very difficult when
my family believes very strongly
about some of these things so my hard
work my hard question for you leah is
this
why do you get a vote
into how your sister chooses to
live out her faith that she says she has
and live out her loving relationship
which she says she's going to do
because it sounds like you you're
putting a lot of heat and a lot of
she's not thinking this through she's
gonna end up like this
she's gonna have these challenges down
the road and that sounds like
you're bringing your baggage to that
situation
well i've seen how it's worked out in
other family situations
and the hurt that yeah it is
you know her relationship but
inevitably it does affect other family
members
especially when kids become involved
that i just
i i just don't want that hurt for her
and for her future
um and the suckiest part about being in
a relationship with somebody
is they can only make that decision for
themselves not you
right and at this point
you have two choices you can speak your
heart and mind and then say
i'll love you and support you or you can
say i don't approve of your
um decisions plural and i'm out
i'm not talking to you anymore i'm
breaking up with you as your sister
and i'll tell you i've seen both of
sides of those and one of those
is a treacherous ugly
gut-wrenching decision that takes
generations to unwind
and the other is frustrating and
annoying but people end up getting
closer and closer over the long term
it's at the end of the day here's the
deal your sister has to make these
decisions and
if she marry somebody who's doesn't
share the same faith
as her will that be hard maybe values
wise yeah they have to have some hard
values conversations
i've also seen folks who say i'm
christian you're christian we both love
jesus and they get married and they
never have the values conversation just
like the previous caller right
and loving jesus means something totally
different to one than it does to the
other
and so sometimes the shared religion
helps bypass a conversation about values
that people should have had a long time
ago
and so it may be that your sister enters
into a relationship
that they have to have really hard
direct conversations about what values
looks like and beliefs
are and here's how we're going to raise
our kids we are going to go to church we
are going to do these things
um and at the end of the day it's her
decision and her and her
future husband's decision to make the
challenge then
becomes are your parents going to let
those
kids come to thanksgiving are you going
to be
cool aunt leah who's going to have the
kids over
just because their dad's not a christian
that's the that's the conversation
you're going to have to make
less about them and their kids now hear
me say this
i don't want for one second to doubt
your heart in this deal
my guess is you really love your sister
and you really want to um
you really want her to be loving and
whole and have a great
life but my my guess here also and tell
me if i'm wrong
is that you are you married now
i am i'm married and i have a toddler
okay so my guess
my other guess is you have this picture
of this this future thanksgiving dinner
this future christmas um this future
birthday party
that this guy and his values and beliefs
or let's just say his beliefs don't fit
into that picture
and suddenly you're having to grieve
this future
fantasy for lack of better words this
future picture that you had for your
family
because your sister's making different
decisions and so really
well it's not so much hurtful for me as
like that's more so how my parents feel
and those arguments that start to happen
you know when it's my son's birthday
party it's like guys
can't we get along and not have these
arguments
and that's where you as a mom have to
that's exactly right what you just did
you have to draw the boundaries
that's your job which is hey guys if
y'all gonna come to my house during my
kid's birthday party and fight you're
not gonna be welcome here
and those are really hard conversations
between adult kids and their parents
but that's your job as your child's
mom right um that's that's where you
draw the line and say
we're not gonna have this conversations
here everybody in the family is welcome
at my house
including my sister and her husband and
whatever kids are gonna have all that
that's on you to draw those boundaries
not your parents and quite honestly they
don't get a vote
they don't get a vote and i know that
sounds so harsh and hard and
but they don't oh it's so hard yeah
right it is
so my recommendation to you is this i
recommend that you
call your mom and dad and say hey i want
to have a future talk
about sister and don't do it on the
phone they're going to feel caught off
guard when people get caught off guard
they
they go with their first gut instinct
which is often
not a smart thing they say things that
they can't get back cetera say next
saturday i want to have a phone call
with you and dad
to talk about um sister and her fiance
and in that conversation you tell your
mom and dad guys
i'm done talking about this i know how
you feel
i know this idea of unequally yoked i
know there's
um bible verses that say you know
um believers should marry non-believers
and um i get where y'all are coming from
but that's my sister and she knows how
we all feel
and she says she's gonna marry this guy
and she's gonna have a family with this
guy and
i'm gonna love my sister and so from
this point forward mom and dad i am not
a place
for you to talk bad about my sister
anymore
and there may be some silence there
there may be some awkwardness there
there may be some well i can't believe
whatever
my guess is over time they will respect
you
deeply for drawing that boundary and if
nothing else
you will respect you for drawing that
boundary and then
have a similar conversation with your
sister which is this
mom and dad have religious beliefs
have faith beliefs that
tell them what you're doing isn't smart
and wise for your heart
it's not smart and wise for your family
and for our family
you believe differently i love you but i
also am tired of talking about mom and
dad tired of
rolling her eyes about mom and dad i'm
tired of beating up mom and dad so
we're done with that i will talk to you
about you and your future husband
i will talk to you about my beautiful
little toddler your niece or nephew
um we can talk about our knuckleheaded
husbands or our great house whatever
but we're not talking about mom and dad
anymore draw the line draw the boundary
because here's the deal at the end of
the day
that's all you can control leah that's
the only
the only thing you can do is control
your thoughts and your actions
and if you do have this attitude of
frustration of
judgment of my sister's making the worst
mistake of her life
she might be but they're her decisions
to make
they're her frustrating things to make
and all you can control is your
boundaries my hope is my hope is
is that you'll be honest you'll be up
front and you'll be
clear but at the end of the day your
default setting will be one of
inclusivity and love
that's my hope that's my prayer go get
em leah go get em all right let's let's
go right back to the calls let's take
robin from atlanta georgia robin how in
the world are you
hey john thank you for taking my call
thank you for calling robin
yeah i'm excited about your new show hey
thank you so much thanks for being on it
yeah sure um i have a stepson now i just
got married
two weeks ago but i i was dating his
father for
three years and he had two weeks prior
to us getting married
he was admitted to a treatment center
for 30 days for opioid
addiction and the re
rehab center has not contacted
you know my husband about what to do
when he gets out this sunday and you
know
setting guidelines he has a history of
drug abuse he has actually stolen
pills from me after i had surgery major
surgery and then
my husband had major surgery he i
actually caught him
stealing them um and we confronted him
he denied it and then he came back and
you know
did say yes i did take him i've had
this addiction since he had had like
hand surgery
when he was like 16. sure so so
you've got a um a i guess a new
son-in-law for lack of better terms
who's an adult yeah i'm assuming
uh yeah a stepson who is you know he
just turned 21 he still lives with his
mother
okay um and so what's your question for
me how can i help
my question is how do we draw boundaries
because
you know i would have thought that the
rehab center would have contacted the
parents and say okay this is what he
needs to do when he gets out no not for
an adult kid
no way really no not for an adult kid um
okay that's not gonna happen he's a
grown man he's a grown man
and as far as as far as the courts are
concerned as far as
as far as his therapists are concerned
his rehab folks
they would never call a brand new
stepmom ever
and so not me normally your father or
his mother yeah
i know it's not my my deal at all but
you know i care for him and i just want
that you know i keep telling my husband
hey y'all need to come up with some
boundaries like requirements if he's
you know he's on his dad's insurance
plan he's on his dad's car insurance
which he is pulling him off of that
because he was probably driving while
you know under the influence of drugs um
and that could affect you know my
husband you know and his
liability as far as you know it being in
his name but as far as boundaries like
hey you need to
you know go to out patient you know
counseling
you need to have drug tests every week
or you know however
and i just need to know how to you know
help my husband decide
what kind of boundaries to set or did we
just act like
it's normal that he's been in treatment
for 30 days
no i in fact you nailed it you
when he gets out you have a welcome home
like a
a welcome out celebration
you take him out to breakfast or to
lunch and you tell him that he's loved
and you're excited that he's back and
then you tell him
um that you're rooting for him and
you're cheering for him
and then you set a date for a couple of
days later two days three days later
and you say we're going to have a
boundaries conversation
because you're out and we want to be a a
part of
your life moving forward and a part of
being in you being a part of our life
moving forward is
you're gonna have to get your own car
insurance you're gonna have to have your
own place to live
you're gonna have to um pay your way
if you steal from us we're gonna call
the police
it's just it's just like you laid it out
what it sounds like
is your husband's nervous about making
that
those boundaries about drawing those
lines about really wrapping things up
and um that can be from
guilt that can be from um
goodness who knows man it can be from um
frustration it can be from annoyance at
his first wife who knows where those the
the
the
the challenges of drawing boundaries at
end of the day
you just what you just said take them
out and draw the boundaries
that means that you and your husband
your new husband are gonna have to
also go have your own conversation about
what those boundaries are going to be
what are they going to look like what
are they going to
sound like what are are we going to hold
them to it and
are we going to hold him accountable if
he violates those boundaries
what happens when you come home and he's
in your in your living room
after you told him he's got to call you
what happens when
he quote unquote borrows some money
or what happens when he comes home and
he is all in on getting well
totally invested kicking butt working
hard
are you going to be able to forgive him
are you going to be able to love him
are you going to be able to let him go
to his mom's house where you don't like
the way things are handled over there
and come back to your house you and your
husband are gonna have to deal with your
hearts on this deal
and really come up with some clear
boundaries for you guys
before you start putting boundaries on
somebody else that's my thought on that
one
i appreciate your call robin so as we
wrap up to the show
today we're gonna go to the lyric of the
day
the song lyric of the day and this is
from a 2013 record
you know there's a lot of records made
in 2013 there's been a lot of records
made i don't know in the past
couple hundred years and when i think
back what are the best records ever made
one kind of emerges to the top and it's
the 2013 record by john mayer
called paradise valley and on that
record
john mayer writes an extraordinary song
called dear marie
here's the lyric of the day dear marie
tell me what it was i used to be oh dear
marie
tell me what it was i used to be and if
you're further up the road
can you show me what i still can't see
remember me
i'm the boy you used to love when you
were 15.
and now i wonder what you think when you
see me in a magazine
dear marie tell me do you still believe
in me
because i got my dream but you got a
family
yeah i got that dream but i guess it got
away from me
john mayer this is the dr john dolone's
[Music]
show